today we're going to be looking at a
geometry problem now what I'd like to do
my plan for this video is to actually
show you three ways to solve the problem
and before I do that I actually it just
occurred to me only just recently that
I've been doing this for a really long
time actually uh right now it's November
2022 which means this YouTube channel
has actually existed for almost exactly
10 years and I it just it kind of blows
my mind that I've been doing this for
that long I'm really old and it's not
just for as long as I've been recording
videos but it's also for as long as I've
been a teacher that I've Loved
um having different ways to solve a
problem and that's a big thing in
mathematics and the reason why I point
out that I've been doing this for 10
years is because I've got evidence of
how much I will go at the same problem
or the same concept and solve it or look
at it in different ways and it occurred
to me that even though I actually do
this a lot in my work with teachers for
those who aren't aware a lot of my work
is not just teaching classes it's
actually supporting teachers other
Educators to give them what we call
Professional learning which is like how
do you become a better teacher I have
been learning through my 15 years of
teaching are constantly how to improve
and I love helping other teachers
improve too because I know it makes a
difference to the students that we teach
and so when I'm delivering professional
learning to other teachers this is a
thing that I emphasize quite a bit and
it occurred to me that I don't talk
about it much here in in these videos so
I kind of just wanted to make a brief
note before I dive into this problem
about why it is that I love uh solving
problems in multiple ways and in fact
why I've come to realize that
particularly over the last yeah I guess
five to six years I've developed I guess
a taste for a prob the kind of problem
that I like to solve it's the sort of
thing which I look at and I'm like oh
here's a solution and then I think oh
there's another way to look at this
problem that makes it sort of unfold in
an easier way there's a very elegant
solution and it's it's interesting to
have a look at that and actually the
more different solutions I can find to a
problem I've come to learn about myself
the more interesting and fascinating I
find that problem and I think the reason
why I've kind of developed this taste is
number one
um I have learned it from other people I
think when I think about you know what
it means to be a great mathematician or
a great mathematics educator it's often
exactly that ability to take on a New
Perspective that takes a problem which
used to be very complex and then Delta
key Insight or shows a parallel or
connection that wasn't obvious that
makes the problem easy to solve it's
kind of like a oh if only you do this it
just kind of falls apart and is very
straightforward that's a really
satisfying feeling I've come to realize
and so what I've I've sort of developed
for myself is
um a desire to seek out problems where
there there are lots of different ways
to think about the problem lots of
different ways to solve it and even
though you might say well you know one
way is better than another we kind of
call that strategic competence you think
about all the different strategies and
you pick the one that's most efficient
this is actually one of the things that
I know I struggled with when I was at
school it's part of why I a lot of the
exams that I did I didn't finish I knew
how to solve the problems but I chose an
inefficient path through that problem
and so it took me this long rather than
this long then I ran out of time to
actually complete the exam so there is
that as a priority you know often in
life we want to do things in a timely
fashion but also one of the things that
I want to give to all of my students or
give us the wrong word one of the things
I want to cultivate in all of my
students and help my students themselves
grow which I guess by extension is you
if you're watching this video is not
just strategic competence but strategic
flexibility and that's the ability to
choose between different methods and to
roll between them sort of quite
comfortably and say hey this isn't just
a problem you can look at in one way you
want to be able to take another
perspective on things and I guess that
is not just powerful in mathematics that
is also just powerful in life a lot of
trying to function effectively in the
world and how to understand other people
and and get along with them is to be
able to take on other perspectives
especially those perspectives that are
not instinctive or natural to you so I
guess that's one of the things I love
about mathematics that it it grows and
and stretches my own ability to see from
different perspectives and that's
something which you useful all the time
everywhere so
without further Ado we're going to have
a go at this problem and what I'm going
to do is show you these three solutions
in order of I guess in order of number
one efficiency and number two in order
of kind of the way that I would think
that you would go about these like I'm
going to show you the first solution as
the classic solution the the one that
probably the teacher had in mind or the
um exam task Setter or who or whoever
wrote this question whatever they had in
mind when they set the question this is
what I think that's the first solution
I'm going to show you the second
solution is kind of it's kind of cute it
gets at a different another very common
area of mathematics that will align
quite nicely with the first solution
that I show you and then the last
solution is one that uh I learned it
from someone who themselves said you
know this is not a solution you would
ever recommend as kind of like hey use
this as a technique it's going to be
really handy in an exam it's actually
very slow and inefficient but it's
clever in its own way and when we get to
that solution to that method we'll
discuss why so here we go let's have a
look at this problem which involves a
square that's been divided up I mean
this question as I've shown it to you
doesn't even tell you what the question
is but I think you can probably guess
here is this Square uh it's a a c d f
um it is its dimensions are one
centimeter by one centimeter and then
you have this shaded region in here uh b
g e h and the as you might be able to
guess
um I guess I could do a sort of hey
notice in Wonder question what do you
think about this as you might be able to
guess the question is what is the area
of bgeh what's the Shaded region so the
way I decided to tackle this first was I
thought I would redraw my diagram
because this is the question that was
posed by someone else and it's obviously
like a blurry picture it's actually not
a bad diagram to use but I I decided I
would draw a sort of clearer version
same thing same situation but it just
allows me to kind of manipulate it and
draw on top of it a little more easily
and the first technique that I'm going
to use involves similar triangles so
maybe I should should write that let's
uh let me move this down give myself a
bit more space so I'm going to call this
method one similar triangles now before
I dive in to the similar triangles the
first question you should have is how
did I even know that there were similar
triangles involved and the most obvious
answer to that question is I've done
questions like this before so I
recognize it but more fundamentally like
that's not very helpful how do I dig
into the reasoning behind how I know
there are similar triangles
especially because the area itself that
we're trying to determine like part of
what's challenging is it is well it's
not a triangle it's a quadrilateral but
not only is it a quadrilateral it's a
weird quadrilateral so you can't work
out or you can't easily work out its
area just by using a formula by saying
oh it's a rectangle or a parallelogram
or a trapezium and I have a formula for
that right so we are going to need to
think about bgeh in terms of the shapes
around it and that's what makes me
recognize that there's there's these
triangles immediately around it and
these triangles here if for example uh
let's let's focus in on say this
triangle here this is a b g
if you compare it to the triangle
beneath it triangle e f g
you might have like kind of an eye to
see that those two are similar but I can
I can sort of show very quickly why they
have to be similar it's worth pointing
out in in solving this question which is
just saying hey what's the area I just
evaluate it I'm not going into a long
proof about why these are similar so I'm
not going to lay that out because this
is not a it's not a deductive geometry
proof it's just a an area measurement
however I do want to show why it's
actually true that they're similar
triangles because I'm going to rely on
that fact the first thing I notice is if
I'm looking for similar triangles uh
firing away the easiest way to prove
that two triangles are similar is to
look at their angles because so long as
you have angles that are the same you're
going to have a similar pair of similar
triangles there are other ways but this
is the easiest way
you can see for instance angle AGB and
angle EGF they're vertically opposite so
they have to be equal and then when you
look at the top and the bottom say for
example a an angle like ABG
compared to an angle like EFG those are
going to be alternate angles on Parallel
Lines because a b and EF these this sort
of top edge here and this one down the
bottom they're going to be parallel
because of this square that you've got
handed from the beginning right so since
I know that this is parallel to this
that gives me the alternate angles
um and I mean you could use the same
proof to sort of look at the other ones
but once you've got two angles or two
pairs of angles being equal in trade was
the third one has to be equal so
therefore two angles is or two pairs of
angles is sufficient I can say bam
they're equal angular and therefore
these are similar triangles now what can
I do with these similar triangles let me
get rid of these markings because I'm
going to use this space in a second I
know that the corresponding sides in
similar triangles are going to be in
proportion or in the same ratio and so
for example the ratio from a b to EF
whatever that ratio happens to be would
match the ratio
from say EG to a g those two sides are
also the corresponding sides there now I
could do that however like what I want
to do is work out the area of
um some of these these figures here like
say for example if you look at uh what
did I say started off b g e h right you
can see that this blue area it sits
inside a larger triangle d b f and so
what I really need to do is subtract
away this green triangle here and then I
guess I'd have to deal with this
triangle over here on the right hand
side in a very similar fashion so if I
can work out this area here I'm good I'm
done right and to work out its area the
most simple way I mean I've got a few
different tricks up my sleeve for it but
given the information that I have here
I've got the base already I just need
the height right if I've got that then
half base height that gives me the area
of EFG and I'm good to go I'll repeat
the same kind of reasoning over here
with d e h
so therefore instead of saying the
corresponding sides in similar triangles
are in proportion uh because I want the
height the height of a triangle is not
always a side in the Triangle in fact
it's only a side of the triangle when
you've got a right angle triangle so
what I really want is this perpendicular
height here
which is not a side in the Triangle but
it is a length in the Triangle that
still corresponds in the same way that
the sides correspond and therefore they
are in the same ratio so I guess the
path I'm taking is I can determine
fairly easily this ratio a b to this
ratio EF and that means I can make a
comparison between the heights of these
two similar triangles all I need to do
is to give them names and then I can
actually do the calculation to determine
the relationship between them and then
off I go okay so what I'm going to do is
given that this triangle down here in
the bottom left EFG this is the one that
I want the height of I'm going to call
that X
and even though I could denote the other
um height over here the corresponding
height in the other cylind triangle I
could denote it with another letter I
don't need to I've got enough
information in this question to denote
it using the same letter
um and it's a relationship with that
letter because this vertical height is
just going to be equal to one therefore
I can call this height here rather than
giving it another perennial rule I can
call it one take away X and that's going
to give me the relationship between
these two okay so my reasoning if I
needed to write it would be uh
corresponding lengths in similar
triangles are in proportion and then I
would launch into saying well okay I'm
going to say X over 1 take away X so the
smaller height divided by the larger
height is going to be equal to the
smaller base which in this case is a
quarter
divided by the larger base which in this
case is a half so I'm just going to put
brackets around those fractions because
I've got fractions on fractions I want
to be careful
so that gives me something that's pretty
easy to deal with what I'll do is on the
right hand side just so that I don't
have um such messy numbers to deal with
I'll multiply the numerator and the
denominator by four so that gives me on
the top oh one and on the bottom a 2 so
that gives me X over one take away X on
the left hand side now I'm going to
cross multiply so that gives me 2x on
the left
one take away X on the right I'll add X
to both sides there's still a 1 over
there so sorry adding One X there's
already two x there gives me 3x so that
gives me x equals a third so now I know
the height of that triangle I already
know the base as you can see over here
and so I'm good to go right over on the
right hand side I'm going to rehearse
this argument and I'm going to say well
I've got a height here that I'm
interested in I guess we'll call that y
I've got a different height here so
we'll call that one take away y
and then I can say well let's use the
same reasoning but I've got a different
pair of uh or set of lengths right so
I'm going to go y over one take away y
is going to be equal to well in this
case I've got three quarters as the uh
the the base that corresponds to the
base the corresponds to this height and
then I've got a huff
over here I'll do the same thing
multiply by four to get rid of those
denominators there so y on one take away
y I'm going to get three on the
numerator and then I'm going to get two
of the denominator just like I got
before
now I'll do my cross multiplication so
2y equals 3 take away 3y add 3y to both
sides and so now I've got
a height okay happy times so at this
point I'm pretty much ready to go the
actual area that I want the area is uh
what do we call it b g e h what it's
equal to is this larger triangle which
is I think we said it was BDF so area
triangle BDF and then what I'm going to
subtract is these two other areas um
that I I'm going to get from those
triangles right which is the area of
this green triangle here is EFG
and then the triangle which I was
dealing with on the right hand side
let's label that it's area let's see
here d e h t e h like so
all right so BDF it has a base of one it
has a height of one so therefore its
area is going to be a half and then when
I'm doing these calculations here I'll
do a half times the base times the
height that I worked out
then I'm going to do the same process
over here a half times this base times
this new height that I worked out three
fifths
okay I'm almost there just need to tidy
up these fractions so I've got
um one over two times four times three
lastly I checked that was 24 and then
this purple triangle what have I got on
the numerator that's a nine
and then on the denominator that's 2
times 20 which is 40 and if you go ahead
and you calculate this uh you can double
check you should get seven over thirty
so this is units squared if I wanted to
actually put the right thing there
because I like to know it's not unit
squared it's actually square centimeters
that's handy let's put that in there
bit cheeky me to add the units in there
at the end without writing them all the
way along through but I think you get
the right idea so there you go that's
the area that I'm after and just doing a
quick sense check right we know that the
whole area here is uh one by one so it's
a square centimeter is this whole shape
that I'm dealing with 7 over 30 that is
roughly that's very close to 7 over 28
so that's a quarter so this is a little
bit less than a quarter and I build that
and you're like yeah that looks about
half of half of the uh of the shape
there of the square so I'm pretty
content that this is the correct answer
and of course you can go back through
all of our different operations and
equations to check the logic that we use
there